Washington DC that has put our nation at
top of $33 trillion debt that has led to
you know $2 trillion annual deficits in
our near future and the rapid Global
dollarization of the economy you look at
the bricks system you know Brazil Russia
India China South Africa they're moving
away from the dollar moreover you've se
you saw us news say that the number one
economic trend of 2023 is D
dollarization globally and if this
country is going down and if we're
losing the dollar I am going down
fighting and I don't care if that means
fighting Republicans Democrats the uni
party the leadership the packs the
lobbyists I've had it I've been here
seven years we don't have a budget we
haven't had one since the mid 90s it was
pretty much fairly obvious that we were
going to get to something like this like
having McCarthy out altogether I think
is the surprise but like the fight that
was going to brew between these guys was
was very very obvious